wir blicken ins leben
sf dok
die weder familie noch schweizer in
englisch ein secondo wir schon genau in
die arme
damit starten dass sie trotzdem bremen
auf details und das große ganze der
filteranlage sie hätte mutter bisher aus
unterschiedlichsten perspektiven
die ganze sache
wir zeigen was menschen bewegt sie
sollen endlich eine lösung finden
ohne krieg auch wenn tränen fließen
meine nächte die man ein alptraum aus
angst regiert niemals glauben und mit
der kamera ausziehen so leben wir kein
wasser kein weg nicht trainiert und dann
klappt
es ist nicht mehr so dass religion gebe
jetzt selbst machen zu wollen und sollen
die materialien hoch nämlich in frage
darunter der auswahl und es geht energie
wir sagen danke an alle
öffnen
so einzigartig
wie das leben